salve a tutti
il mio viaggio comincia ad un incrocio
l'incrocio tra design e scienza con una
valigia piena di stupore lo stupore che
di solito provo di fronte alla bellezza
generosa e gratuita del pianeta durante
questo viaggio sperimentato tre cose ho
sperimentato il potere del design al
fine di generare comprensione attraverso
chiarezza emozioni ed interesse
ho sperimentato che comunicare la
scienza senza un dialogo continuo e
costante con gli scienziati può generare
falsi miti e messaggi fuorvianti
più di tutto sperimentato che non
possiamo ignorare il ritmo delle risorse
naturali da cui la nostra vita dipende
noi utilizziamo queste risorse per
produrre per costruire per muoverci per
nutrirci e inevitabilmente generiamo un
impatto sulla natura attraverso rifiuti
ed emissioni
ora la natura deve prendere queste
rifiuti ed emissioni
eri trasformarli in risorse c'è un
piccolo problema però perché noi siamo
molto più veloci a trasformare le
risorse in rifiuti rispetto al ritmo con
cui la natura riesce a trasformare i
rifiuti in risorse cioè andiamo molto
più veloce come svuotare un secchio
molto più velocemente di quanto possa
essere riempito per spiegarlo in termini
finanziari
l'umanità ha un dono preziosissimo un
capitale naturale fisso questo capitale
naturale fisso produce degli interessi
naturali ogni anno ora dagli anni 70
circa
noi abbiamo cominciato ad utilizzare di
più degli interessi naturali quindi
abbiamo cominciato ad erodere il
capitale naturale fisso che non si
rigenera e quindi mettiamo a rischio non
soltanto il capitale naturale fisso ma
anche gli interessi
e naturali che questo capitale può
generare chiediamo al pianeta più di
quanto sia possibile siamo tecnicamente
in una condizione che si chiama di
overshoot ora questa condizione di
overshoot ha le sue radici in
contraddizioni profonde che possiamo e
dobbiamo risolvere quando ho cominciato
il mio viaggio
credevo che tutto quello che ci fosse da
sapere su una goccia d'acqua fosse
visibile tangibile miss corresse tra le
mani
credevo che la cosa importante fossero
quei 50.000 litri all'anno per persona
del consumo domestico che ciascuno di
noi usa per bere per fare la doccia per
lavarsi i denti
in realtà questo rappresenta soltanto la
punta di un iceberg perché ci sono due
storie importantissime molto più
importanti c'è l'acqua che viene
utilizzata per produrre i prodotti
industriali che consumiamo ogni giorno e
quel valore ammonta a 61 mila litri per
persona ogni anno ma poi c'è una storia
ancor più importante che l'acqua che
viene utilizzata per produrre il cibo
che consumiamo e quel valore ammonta a
un milione 274 mila litri per persona
ogni anno quindi il 92 per cento
dell'acqua che utilizziamo si nasconde
nel cibo che mangiamo
ora il cibo comincia o comunque è il
risultato di un viaggio lunghissimo un
viaggio lunghissimo che mobilità delle
risorse preziosissime non solo acqua il
problema è che in economia come la
nostra noi buttiamo via tantissimo cibo
la fao ci dice che di tutto il cibo che
viene prodotto su scala mondiale
un terzo non raggiunge il nostro stomaco
quest hearts pari a un miliardo e 300
milioni tonnellate di cibo ogni anno
eliminare questo spreco vorrebbe dire
fare fronte al 60 per cento del
fabbisogno di cibo
qui dovremo far fronte nei prossimi 70
anni quando
unite ci dicono che saremo circa 3
miliardi in più ma dov'è che sprechiamo
il cibo è il risultato di un viaggio che
parte probabilmente in campi coltivati
lontani migliaia di chilometri da noi e
continua attraverso tutte le fasi della
filiera produttiva
lo spreco avviene lungo tutte queste
fasi durante la fase di produzione
agricola durante la fase di lavorazione
industriale come il packaging durante la
fase di distribuzione durante la fase di
ristorazione e a casa perché avviene lo
spreco ci sono le ragioni più assurde
per ragioni di natura estetica ad
esempio perché i prodotti non sono belli
da vedere perché sono stati colpiti da
grandine
oppure perché non sono sufficientemente
dritti da pelare per ragioni di mercato
se al contadino viene liquidato un
prezzo che è inferiore al costo della
raccolta al contadino conviene lasciar
marcire la frutta nei campi e 9 nel 2009
in italia per questo motivo come ci
dicono segre falasconi abbiamo buttato
via 17 milioni e 700mila tonnellate di
frutta e verdura
ci sono ragioni commerciali problemi di
pezzatura e prodotti sono troppo piccole
troppo grandi ci sono errori nel
packaging ci sono problemi di
conservazione problemi di gestione delle
scorte perché sugli scaffali nei nostri
supermercati
abbiamo fino a quattro volte di più
rispetto a quello di cui abbiamo bisogno
ci sono problemi nella lettura delle
etichette
poi ci sono le nostre abitudini
compriamo troppo e cuciniamo troppo
secondo voi suo cerca è l'osservatorio
internazionale per lo spreco del cibo
soltanto in italia il valore dello
spreco lungo tutta la filiera ammonta a
circa 15 miliardi di euro
ora se per un attimo mettiamo da parte
la fase di coltivazione ci concentriamo
sulla lavorazione la distribuzione la
ristorazione e il consumo a casa
eurostat ci dice che
europa ogni anno buttiamo via 89 milioni
di tonnellate di cibo così distribuite
35 milioni di tonnellate per la fase
della lavorazione industriale del 5 per
cento 4 milioni di tonnellate nella fase
della distribuzione e della vendita 12
milioni di tonnellate nella ristorazione
il 42 per 138 milioni di tonnellate
all'anno a casa ora concentriamoci un
attimo su questi 38 milioni di
tonnellate all'anno guardiamoli un po
più da vicino sono 76 kg di cibo che
ciascuno di noi
spreca in media ogni anno 76 kg e ogni
chilo di questo spreco non è soltanto
spreco di cibo e anche lo spreco di
tutte le risorse che sono state
utilizzate per produrlo la fao stima che
il consumo di acqua dolce necessari a
produrre lo speck lo spreco di cibo su
scala mondiale equivale a 250 mila
miliardi di litri di acqua che equa
eguagliano lo scarico idrico annuale del
volga nel mar caspio
la fao stima che il cibo prodotto è
sprecato su scala mondiale richiede 1,4
miliardi di ettari di terra il 30 per
cento dell'area mondiale coltivabile
la fao stima che le emissioni del cibo
prodotto è buttato su scala mondiale
sono pari a circa 3,3 miliardi di
tonnellate di co2
se lo spreco di cibo fosse un paese
sarebbe sterzo in graduatoria per
emissioni di co2 dopo usa e cina che
fare possiamo cominciare dalle nostre
case questa è una bella notizia perché
nelle nostre case se ci consiglia se
consideriamo i 76 kg
da domani senza aspettare nessuna legge
nessuna regolamentazione possiamo
abbattere lo spreco del 60 per cento che
è il valore evitabile dello spreco
quindi noi da domani possiamo abbattere
lo spreco ogni anno di 50 chili in
italia e nel mondo ci sono delle persone
stanno facendo cose straordinarie per
coinvolgere cittadini leader politici e
scienziati
l'obiettivo è cercare di raggiungere una
gestione sostenibile delle risorse del
pianeta e dobbiamo smettere di pensare
che questo non sia una priorità della
nostra agenda politica
dobbiamo ricominciare dalle nostre
singole azioni che dobbiamo essere
cittadini attivi e leader attivi questo
signore denis meadows è un famoso
scienziato e professore gestione dei
sistemi famosissimo per le sue ricerche
sulla gestione sostenibile delle risorse
del pianeta e fa un esercizio
interessantissimo che vorrei stare con
voi perché è una bella metafora del
messaggio che vorrei lasciare oggi
allora per fare questo esercizio vorrei
che avesse le mani libere e le braccia
libere quindi ora che poggiasse a terra
sulle ginocchia tutto quello che non vi
serve
ok adesso vorrei che incrociare le
braccia
vorrei che guardasse in basso e
controllate ricordaste qual è il polso
che avete in alto potete allungare le
braccia incrociate le braccia di nuovo
ora che guardasse in basso ricordasse
qual è il polso che avete in alto potete
allungare il braccio
grazie allora chi di voi tutte e due le
volte ammesso lo stesso polso in alto
alzate la mano me compresa ok quasi
tutti noi quindi questo dimostra che
ognuno di noi ha un modo ottimale di
incrociare le braccia circa ci
incavoliamo in quel modo
chi di voi tutte e due le volte ammesso
in alto il polso sinistro assi la mano
in alto il polso destro
alzi la mano bene 50 per cento e 50 per
cento questo dimostra che possiamo
incrociare le braccia
in tutti e due modi però ci incanaliamo
nel nostro modo ottimale
e ci incastriamo c incanaliamo in quella
abitudine ora bellissimi do si dice
negli ultimi 200 anni circa abbiamo
creato un sistema e degli indicatori per
misurare il successo e tutto è andato
avanti
adesso però il contesto è cambiato e
dobbiamo cambiare abitudini e cominciamo
subito
vorrei che incrociare le braccia
mettendo in basso il polso che avevate
in alto
perfetto è un piccolo esercizio che ci
fa notare tre cose molto interessanti
che sono vere anche per raggiungere il
nostro obiettivo di sviluppo sostenibile
è possibile dobbiamo rifletterci
all'inizio sembra non essere una
posizione rilassante e lo diventerà ma
ci vuole coraggio ci vuole il coraggio
di pianificare nel lungo periodo e di
puntare ad una gestione sostenibile
delle risorse del pianeta perché un
pianeta sano nel lungo periodo sarà
molto più vantaggioso di un pianeta al
collasso nel breve e poi ci vuole il
coraggio di usare la forma di potere più
grande che abbiamo che è l'azione
l'azione ora non domani non tra un mese
non tra un anno perché quello che fa la
differenza non è decidere di agire ma
agire e secondo me è la variabile tempo
che ci permetterà di costruire un futuro
meraviglioso
grazie a tutti